alright I'm sitting here with the author
of your new favorite self output uh suck
less I write books now hi I'm well um
exactly we didn't do this dr. John Tesh
made me famous by John Tesh he was an
anchor - he wasn't anchor loved him who
are some of your favorite anchors I like
to marry her a [ __ ] oh very hard
without feathering all the legs Oh
everything nothing about this book
because it like thank you for keeping it
real you know right how did this come
together there's binding in between and
it just holds on page of them like all
the things are here like you know I
started writing because I helped Neil
Patrick Harris with drag for Hedwig and
then he's like Wow he kept asking me
questions I was like it's like I know
something you're trying to help people
find their sparkle right yeah I mean I
think everything would be better with a
drag queen best friend I'm a good time
like if you're ever bored and you have a
bunch of numbers in your phone you're
like Oh one's a drag queen and be like
let me go there I'll call ya it's
probably up snacks probably something
cute to wear just probably help me with
my makeup how did you get Neil Patrick
Harris to write the foreword it sounds
like he owed you a favor I text him say
hey [ __ ] huh
RuPaul definitely not gonna do this for
me so how about you help me out um and
he did I thought he would I would get
like three lines everything I'll write
it for you just sign your name or
whatever said it from your email to them
he's good at everything he does and he's
the nicest guy in the world the book it
covers a lot of ground like how did you
leave it did you have a list going in of
what you wanted to tackle I asked the
people on the Internet to follow me like
hey what do you want to hear about a lot
of it was like coming out to my family
how to you know cover up cold sore pits
with skin problems do drag better all
that little stuff that I was like over
the years I've learned by mistake
because I never really a drag mom most
of my friends just when I told him I was
writing a book they said how many
pictures are in it does it come with
crayons or the page is going to be
pretty stuck together I want to get your
thoughts on the recent season of drag
race all-stars you know what was your
take on the Fifi drama and did you feel
like she was just heavily edited they
can't show you anything that you don't
give unfortunate for her fortunate for
all the viewers is that they can piece
together things so they can take pick
from stay to piece from day 15 and
sliced together you have to create story
it's just all those girls are so
talented that they could have a show
that just relied on talented but thank
God they don't because drag queens being
mean is the fact I mean that's why we
tune it the only thing better is
directly this fall I want to ask you
this what role do you think the drag and
queer community will play in Trump's
president-elect Trump's America um the
one thing that gave me a little bit of
Solace was watching Trump's introduction
of Peter Thiel the PayPal founder at the
RNC does that could go in a lot of
different ways introducing an openly gay
man at the RNC and Trump seemed Darris a
genuine when he said it warms my heart
to see you guys clapping for my gay
friend Peter Thiel I think that drag
will continue to be the loudest voice
and whenever there's a benefit whenever
there's a parade they'll call us out
we'll be in the trenches doing this we
throw the first bricks we are those on
the loudmouth I love it let's it on a
light note I want to know which lip do
you think needs a a Willem approved
makeover oh it is you know who I love
and she's taking chances but I want to
push her further Margot Robbie okay
there she's got a great sense of style
I mean Harley Quinn was like my dream
like her Harley Quinn was perfect like
very Deborah Harry very early bad Margot
Robbie is amazing seems like she's
making her own choices wish oh oh honey
boo boo ha ha thanks for watching ET on
youtube but why are you in a hurry
before you go all you got to do is click
to subscribe to watch more of our videos